what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I go over this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and let's get
started so today
Kiki Palmer is back so a couple weeks
ago I covered Kiki Palmer going to a
concert and I talked about how one of
the major problems in society is how we
cannot tell the difference between wives
and mothers and honestly 304s hookers
prostitutes and Kiki you know she seems
like a nice lady but you know I don't
know if it's necessarily appropriate for
you to be prancing a long half naked
going to an usher concert so Kiki gets
pulled on stage
and you know she's being all flirtatious
with Usher and you know I thought maybe
you know because it has women sometimes
we just do silly things maybe she would
be like Oh I'm sorry that was out of
pocket
but when Haram the father of her child
said you know I don't think that was
appropriate
um not only did she not apologize she
doubled down
and Kiki actually tripled down this week
because Kiki Palmer is to star in
Usher's new video for his track
boyfriend
[Music]
somebody say that your boyfriend's
looking for me
so he says somebody says that your
boyfriend is looking for me
yeah and you know what it kind of shows
and I was thinking about this we have a
society of really [__]
and the top 10 percent of men
that's really what Society is right now
because you see the key key dated a guy
that made less than her she was
perfectly fine throwing that entire
thing away for five seconds of Fame with
a celebrity that doesn't give a [__]
about her and you know I've said this
before and I'll say it again women we
just have a tendency we would rather be
the king's concubine than the peasant's
wife and I don't know why we're like
this but a million years of evolution
has just made us this way you know in
history we wouldn't typically always
have access to the Kings but social
media and rise to fame has given women
access to the top 10 percent of men but
the problem is that we're so easily
propagated that we really focus on the
wrong things like you know
we'll throw it all away for like an
Entertainer a rapper it's never like the
CEO of a company you know what I mean
it's like I mean it's wrong regardless
but you're just like really an
Entertainer
Who Am I who am I but my point isn't
really about this my point is really you
know I keep hearing from Trad cons that
this is just one instance it's those
women but really it's just a general
Trend across the board you know I
recently found out we have more only
fans workers
than teachers
you know let that sink in more women are
picking sex work than picking an
education career
and you know
um
women and often conservatives will kind
of brainwash you to not believe what's
in front of your eyes but you know we're
in a society where you really can't tell
the difference between hookers only fans
workers and wives they all look the same
and you know then we shame men for
walking away when this is the quality of
what's on the market you know only four
percent of women are virgins on their
wedding days when a hundred years ago
that was a prerequisite for marriage you
could not get married or it was unlikely
you could get married without being a
virgin so you know
um and you certainly would be shamed for
cheating you certainly would be shamed
for wearing provocative outfits in
public like now we've just really lost
like shame as a society and you know I
think like 10 years ago when the
conservative movement it very much was
you know you do you I don't really care
what you do as long as it doesn't affect
me
but the issue that we have is
you know when a society loses shame then
it's kind of like anything goes you know
the issue we have is that when a society
loses shame anything goes you know and
this is the one thing that I think is
very misconstrued people think that if
we're harsh with women that women won't
receive the message but the truth of the
matter is women respond very well to
social shaming women respond very
quickly how do you think we respond so
quickly to fashion trends I mean guys
look at I got these puff sleeves
somebody convinced me to wear these this
you know what I mean it's like women
will be in and out with the latest
fashion trends but yet we're afraid to
shame women in my opinion it's the
destruction of society I think that only
fans when you have a whole generation of
men and women that are raised by only
fans workers strippers porn stars or
just just flat out [__] I think when
that's what you have in society
um how can you raise a generation with
strong morals and values and then we
wonder why we have this crazy Mental
Health crisis how do you not have a
crazy Mental Health crisis when the
women are raising all the men even if
they're married the women typically run
the relationship and then these are the
values that the women are teaching you
know it used to be there used to be a
point in time where men would be able to
rightfully trust women raising kids like
you know the guy would go off to war
he'd be working a lot or whatever it was
and we still produce strong good
children but now it's really sad to be
honest
um
we have wives and mothers that are
posting thirst traps we have wives and
mothers that are flirting with other men
in public
like okay it's wrong regardless but you
at least couldn't do it behind closed
doors it's like you know and this is the
morality that we're teaching the Next
Generation and do you really think
that's fair is it fair to the kids
um and this is why I personally think
that fathers should be the ones raising
the children you know I think there's a
reason that when men are left to their
own devices they naturally do good
things like when you think about it
women we really could be sex slaves like
in cages if men all got together and
said we want to abuse the women the men
literally could do that but they don't
and I think there's something inherently
benevolent about men to women and two
children but for whatever reason when
women get too much power we just are
evil with it um I don't really
understand why we're like this but you
know we're the most likely ones to kill
children we're the most likely ones to
kill the elderly
and
um for whatever reason when left to our
own devices we're just self-destructive
I mean we've had more choice in the last
hundred years than ever
um we can really do anything and you
know when one out of 25 of us is on only
fans under the age of 35
uh you kind of have to question how well
do women really make decisions and I
really think it's because we are just
more emotional beings you know we do
what feels right at the time not what is
right there's a reason like more
masculine adjectives are used for men so
like a man of your word
um honor integrity yeah I mean that
that's something used more with men than
women and for it's weird because when
you think about our language it's like
we have slip UPS so when you have a man
and you say you're acting like a woman
right now that's considered a bad thing
why but if a woman acts like a man it I
I don't want to say
it's definitely not a good thing but
it's not it doesn't have as negative as
a connotation as vice versa and again I
think it's because when women are left
to our own devices we just don't tend to
choose good as a group
sorry guys I don't know what it is
um so the next story is a clip from
fresh and fit what does that have to do
with women building and moving in what
do you mean my mom built everything by
herself she never accepted money from
nobody she never even accepted child
support ask yourself a question who did
she build it up for she build it up for
us for us children but not a man is my
point no why would she have to build it
up for her man the man should have it
himself do not see the point I'm trying
to make here that when women make excess
resources they don't share with men but
when men make excess resources they
share with women
men make money right they become
successful so that they can have a
family dependent upon them women on the
other hand make money become successful
so they can be independent of men
there's a difference
and there you go you know I think Myron
really drove the point home that when
women get power when women get money we
have a tendency to be selfish you know
and I'm not saying all women like I have
a aunt that yeah she worked and
supported her family her whole life like
she was the main Breadwinner but I think
we can understand that there's
exceptions and there's rules and
exceptions definitely do not make the
rule and for whatever reason when women
get power get money
um we're not nice to men you don't
really see women across the board saying
I want to take care of a man
like I'm I'm like joking like laughing
thinking about this it's usually I want
somebody better than me I want someone
that makes more than me and you know I
think a lot of times women we really
don't think of the long game like
women's income flat lines at about 55k
like the average woman in this country
makes 55k and I think she flat lines at
that in
like 30s 40s something like that
um We're Men Flatline in their 50s at
70k and I think a lot of women don't
factor in that men are going to work
longer than you
so even if you have to split bills in
the beginning the idea is most men can
really work till they're 70. and women I
just don't think are built like that
um and so if women want to retire
really it's funny we because as a group
we have to rely on men in some way if
we're in sex work
who's employing us
okay even if you become like a high-end
realtor because a lot of women are going
into real estate who's buying from you
um if you want to live off of the
government who pays the majority of the
taxes
um if you want to divorce your guy and
live off a child support
there you go and so it's funny because
you know we'll scream we're strong and
independent women but women literally
cannot survive without men but men can
survive without women I'm not saying
they'd prefer it but when you look at it
from a society point of view
yeah
the men really they can live without us
but we can't live without them so the
next story is um you know
as women we make super wise decisions
and you know as we've studied women get
divorced for real reasons you know we
are just super abused and have it so
hard and you know when we get divorced
it's for super valid reasons so I regret
so today we have a submission from a
girl talking about her divorce and
actually regretting it she says I regret
not making my marriage work and now my
ex-husband is happily remarried when I
was in my early 30s I divorced my
husband we didn't have any major issues
our relationship was just challenged
after having kids I was a stay-at-home
mom and I expected him to do more of the
housework and the child care when he
worked full-time he did not help me when
I asked but I started to ask more of him
and I burnt him out I used to have him
wrapped around my finger and I used that
as an advantage to get what I want he
eventually got tired of it I started
threatening to divorce him and he said
he knew the baby was just stressing us
out and he will he would like to make it
work but when I was 30 I thought I was a
great catch because I was still very
beautiful for my age and I lost my mom
bod so I thought I could do better than
him so I left him I got
I got our house in the divorce and we
shared joint custody of our son fast
forward now I'm 41 and still single and
my ex-husband is 41 and got remarried to
a 31 year old woman who is incredibly
beautiful they had their daughter three
years ago he bought a new house and my
son loves going to his dad's house to
spend time with his other family and I'm
not gonna lie it makes me jealous she
has it all she took my husband she took
my kid she took my life that was once
all mine and all I have is the house we
created our family in and now I live in
an empty house I'm 41 I gained 20 pounds
I've got wrinkles and I'm alone and
miserable I've had short-term
relationships after the divorce but they
never worked out men just don't want an
old woman like me with a child and I've
noticed that men with kids just have a
better time dating with kids than we do
and I hate it
so there you have it ladies you know and
that's why a lot of people think that
red pill is harsh but the truth of the
matter is that the red pill is honest
and I think a lot of single mothers
leave relationships thinking that
there's better on the other side I think
a lot of single mothers leave the father
of their children for selfish reasons
and you know the media tries to pretend
that women have valid reasons for
divorce when really the truth of the
matter is guys that there's only a
couple you know semi-valid reasons for
divorce abuse adultery addiction I'll
give you guys those
but outside of that like we forget what
the actual vows are first richer or for
poorer in sickness and in health till
death to us part not until we get bored
or thinking that we can do better you
know I I think in America and especially
amongst women we've really lost feeling
content
you know I think social media has
convinced us that there's always a
better option that there is always
something good around the corner and it
really makes us women live in la la land
and you know I really do appreciate the
men that have made content that is
honest to women because what you start
to realize when you get more and more
red pill is guys see see this craziness
you know men typically don't live in la
la land because you know men
more so than women I'll say see what's
true so when we're divorcing for stupid
reasons or like leaving for stupid
reasons the men can see it stupid but
they don't they like guys just they
don't want the drama so a lot of guys
aren't going to tell you
um and that's why I really appreciate
the content that
fresh and fit and a lot of the other red
pill guys have made to really drive the
point home that this isn't in one
culture this isn't in one place this is
women across the board and the general
trends that are overtaking women today
so you know we do Street interviews a
lot and you can really gather a lot of
information from Street interviews
because it's completely random who
you're interviewing and you just do them
all over
um so this guy was interviewing women on
the street and this happened
[__] you you'll [__] me would you though
I would yeah I appreciate it can you get
your number nah I'm cool on it she
working out she see what she liked or I
[__] with it I [__] with the confidence
though you know what I'm saying yeah I'm
gonna come in that [__] all day you know
what I'm saying he can get my number if
he wants it your man calling you right
now oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] oh my God
damn we caught him man we caught him we
caught her
so okay let me get this straight this
chick
she's offering sex to another guy
and then her boyfriend calls and you
know what's funny doing Street
interviews and doing shows it's like I
have talked to so many guys that
were hooking up with the chick and
didn't know she was married hooking up
with the chick and didn't know she had a
boyfriend like women will have a guy
that they're dating while actively
searching for the next best thing and
you know then when guys walk away from
relationships they get mad at the guys
instead of examining the quality of the
product this is the quality of the women
and the wives on the market right now
and you know I can't really blame guys
for not wanting to deal with it
um I just think that's so crazy this
chick
is literally offering sex to another guy
with a boyfriend and then picks up the
call like wild wild you know I often
hear from the guys
are from the Conservative Christian
people
just find a good woman you know
um go find a good woman
yes and I think what they fail to what
they downplay is just how malleable
women are like it's so crazy we'll just
hear some propaganda and just like go
with it you know like we'll watch we
will watch Eat Pray Love
and leave our husband to 15 years and
this is across the board conservative
women
um
liberal women and you know it's it's the
impact of social media has been so
negative on women it's basically like
we're walking around the way that if all
men were addicted to porn that's how
women are walking around so addicted to
social media imagine if a guy left his
wife of 20 years
for an AI I don't know sex doll
girlfriend
but we have women watching Eat Pray Love
and leaving their husbands of 20 years
like this is what these are real stories
this is what is going on in society so
um pull this clip of a Christian woman
calling into a show old I'm married for
30 years to just the most amazing man
we have eight
incredible kids
and um five years ago we took the kids
up to the mountains about three hours
away from home went mountain biking and
he was in he crashed his bike very very
severely suffered
um a traumatic brain injury
that almost killed him
um we spent two I am considering
getting a divorce okay so that I can
move on with my life
okay
nothing with my relationship with my
husband would change that's a great
example of hypergamy
right so women mate across and up
success hierarchies
yeah and so basically her husband like
this is a Christian lady for better for
worse for sickness and in health till
death do us part
a guy helped her with eight kids and you
know life went the wrong way for him now
he's sick
and she's trying to divorce him and you
know that is a really hard situation so
you know I'm not even trying to go in on
her too much but the point is like for
whatever reason women we're just not
very loyal
um and it just seems like whenever
there's a better option A lot of us tend
to go and it seems like whenever the
rubber hits the road and you really have
to work through a hard time you know
nowadays women just have so many backup
options and women have so much leverage
in the sexual Marketplace that there's
no real incentive to stick it out like
in the old days especially now that we
can make our own money and we don't need
men as soon as we made enough money to
not need men we really treat them as
disposable unfortunately okay so the
last story of today so a couple of
months ago there was a lady that went
viral on Twitter
she was on an airplane and had a freak
out because she saw a quote-unquote
non-living entity something like that so
here's the video that initially went
viral
I'm telling you I'm getting the [__] off
and there's a reason why I'm getting the
[__] off with everyone
either Believe it or they cannot believe
it I don't give
but I am telling you right now that
[__] that [__] back
there is not real
and you can sit on this plane and you
can die with him or not I'm not going to
so you know we got this chick
screaming about how some guy on the
plane isn't real now this woman went
radio silent for three weeks and all of
the conservatives on Twitter wanted to
know what happened like everybody's
asking all these questions like what
what did this lady see so you know
additional footage comes out
and yeah this is her after if you don't
leave you'll be uh under arrest or
criminal trespass
this is your warning right here
[Music]
okay
what
am I leaving
ma'am if you don't leave right now she's
gonna be under arrest record trespass
let's go
slight leaves do not let that plate
leave
being dead serious do not let that
slightly
now after three weeks of Silence
she finally comes forward they found out
this lady is a marketing director
and
you know there's a lot of conspiracy
theories they're kind of conjuring but
now she comes forward and issues a
public apology
as you know I
have been unwilling to speak on the
viral video but I do finally feel that
it's time
first and foremost I want to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable
distressed or not I should have been I
should have been in control of my
emotions and
that was not the case
my use of profanity was completely
unnecessary
and I want to apologize to everyone on
that plane especially those that had
children aboard
can imagine going through that and
trying to explain to your kid what in
the world just happened
we all have our bad moments
um some far worse than others and mine
happened to be caught on camera for the
whole world to see multiple times
sorry trying not to sound like Minnie
Mouse
um
well it has been really comical for
everyone and I have highly enjoyed so
many of the means
on the flip side it is very invasive and
unkind
and I don't know what I would do without
the love and support of my friends and
family
they are loyal to a fault and I don't
know what I did to deserve them
um
sorry y'all
I hope that I can use this experience
and do a little bit of good in the world
and that is what I intend to do
I hope that you guys can accept my
apology and I can begin to move on with
my life
so now the internet
has been set Ablaze
Because the Internet does not believe
that this is the same woman who actually
believes this is the crazy plain lady
Tiffany Gomez speaking out who the f are
they trying to kid so that's like the
side by side we got there
I okay my first thought was this is how
[__] look before and after my show
like like on the left that's what they
look like here and on the right is after
they take pictures on this couch and
like Photoshop them
that was that was what I was thinking
but
like to me it kind of looks like an
internet filter but you know a lot of
people are saying that this was
orchestrated to distract us from what's
going on in Hawaii right now so what I
think um is going on in Hawaii is
exactly what's going on in Alberta other
land grabs
um Hawaii is very small it has a small
amount of land available especially for
Millionaires and billionaires that have
houses in these areas that want to keep
building so the easiest way instead of
offering people money for their homes is
to just burn the entire place down and
pretty much burn people out of their
area they did that in Alberta here to
try and get people into 15-minute cities
and I'm pretty sure that's what they're
doing in Maui now why am I saying that
well I did a video on the Epstein flight
log list
exposed everybody that was on the
flights and I also put up uh classified
documents that were from the Gillian
Maxwell court case and then I even put
up her flight log so not just
um
Epstein's flight logs but her flight
logs that were released in court as well
people went absolutely wild the video
went super viral um some people were
super mad at me because their movie
stars were on like on Epstein Island but
if you look at the correlation of the
people who were on Epstein Island and
the people who own houses on Maui you're
gonna see a huge correlation and these
people do not stop at at anything and
they want more land so they can keep
building their entire houses bigger now
the only reason I know this is I went to
Hawaii I think 13 years ago and talking
to the locals they were all complaining
about the same thing over development
developers coming in and trying to take
homes of regular people for way under
the asking price and then building like
multi-million dollar or billion dollar
um hotels homes on that land
so what people started doing is they
won't take any offer from any developer
so what's another way of getting people
off of their land is to burn it Scorch
it or make it literally non-livable on
and I think that's what's happening in
Hawaii whether it was done on purpose
with DW's or you know other forms of
silent weapons or if it was done by one
of these MPC crazy people who believe in
global warming yet they don't really
understand the billionaires and the
millionaires are still taking private
jets they have cruise ship sized private
yachts they're not stopping eating me
they're not stopping flying around the
world so I mean you know there's a bunch
of people out there that will believe
the agenda and then try and push it but
I think this is a lot deeper kind of
like in Alberta and I truly feel for the
people in Hawaii stay strong come
together as a community like we did here
in Alberta and really try and help each
other out
um start a GoFundMe page in case your
insurance company these don't really
come through with you and I hope that we
can all kind of stick together and hope
and pray for Hawaii right now yeah so
I Here's my thought I don't really know
about the whole conspiracy theories but
I've seen a bunch of different like
takes on Twitter but that I would say
that's like the sum of what I've seen
um I do think it was the same lady just
with a filter on you don't you know
[__] and filters right you know what
I mean like we love our filters
um like sometimes after the show some
girls will take selfies with me and the
filters on it I'm like oh my gosh I look
like a different lady
um but
yeah I don't I don't know I
I'm hesitant to say that it's like a a
psyop but I I haven't ruled it out
completely so I guess it'll be
interesting to see the updates in this
development and I will keep you guys
posted
but yeah that's um this week's craziness
treachery debauchery and let me know
what you want me to cover next if you
guys have any submissions make sure you
submit them to my Instagram just
probably things one like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time